احمد صميم طالب كفيف في اكبر مدرسه خاصه
للمكفوفين في كابول يجلس في هذا الفصل مع
شقيق له كفيف ايضا يواصلان الدراسه رغم
وفاه والدهم ومعيلهم الوحيد وياملان في
مستقبل افضل
زرت كثيرا من الاطباء والمشافي في الداخل
والجميع قالوا لي اذهب خارج البلاد للعلاج
الى باكستان او اي بلد اخر خالد هو ايضا
من الطلاب المكفوفين يشكوك بقيه زملائه
صعوبه الحياه في مدينه تخلو من اي تسهيلات
خاصه بذوي الاعاقات البصريه يطلب على
الاقل دعما له ولزملائه لمواجهه تحديات
عمليتهم التعليميه نواجه مشاكل في توفير
الكتب الدراسيه وكذلك في الات برايلر التي
لا توجد في المدرسه الا ق ويحترف بذلك
مدير المدرسه والاساتذه
رئاسه التعليم المهني والتقني وهي الجهه
المسؤوله عن المدرسه تعترف بان الانظمه
السابقه لم تقدم اي خدمات تعليميه مناسبه
لذوي الاعاقات البصريه ان شاء الله فعندك
مجرم ان شاء الله في المستقبل القريب سوف
نقوم بتامين المعدات والاجهزه التي
تحتاجها هذه المدرسه
طلاب مدرسه المكفوفين يتعلمون مهنا مختلفه
بالاضافه الى تعلم منهج وزاره التعليم
والتربيه عبر اله برايلر على الرغم من ان
المدرسه الثانويه المهنيه للمكفوفين تعتبر
مركزا دافئا لهم فانها لا تزال تواجه
مشاكل كثيره ولم يتم ايلاء الكثير من
الاهتمام لهذه المدرسه حتى من قبل
المؤسسات المسؤوله عبر نادر العربيه كابول